Okay.
So we're in the,
uh,
payoff period of having spent all this time on quantum mechanics and we want to
see first whether what we've done is realistic or not.
So last time we looked at h h and h f in terms of what the bond strengths were
and we saw that indeed one of them was more,
uh,
stable for breaking into ions and the other more stable with respect to breaking
into two,
uh,
Adams.
But here's a more extensive reality check today,
which involves a lot more,
uh,
experimental evidence and it has to do with x h three that is the,
the molecules,
B,
h three c,
h three and Nh three.
And we're going to look at their structure and how they move and see how that
checks out with what we expect theoretically.
So first,
what do we expect theoretically?
Well be h three C h three n h three are the same except Boron has three valence
electrons.
Carbon has four and nitrogen has five.
Now each of the uses three of their valence electrons to share with hydrogens to
make the three x h three bonds.
But Boron then has no leftover electrons.
Carbon has one and nitrogen has to.
So we want to see what the implications of this are going to be for the
structure and a dynamic behavior of these molecules.
And then we'll check it against reality.
First we need to look at something that shows that the hybridization that you
use to make bonds should be related to structure.
Now suppose there's one of these atoms that uses an sp hybrid orbital that looks
like,
that.
See the little dot where the nucleus is.
And suppose that happens also,
uh,
in to use some other hybrid orbital to make another bond.
Now you want to have because of the Paoli principle,
and I'm sorry we don't have time to go into this.
Now,
uh,
you,
the orbitals that you're using must not overlap one another because if there's
net overlap between two orbitals then and you have electrons in both of them,
those electrons are to a certain extent the same thing.
If the orbitals overlap,
if they don't overlap,
then they're independent.
So to have only two electrons per orbital,
the orbitals must not overlap.
So we can use that as a criteria to say something about what other orbitals
could be used at certain angles.
For example,
suppose the other hybrid orbital that this Adam was using was sp three.
Now you'll notice that remember the,
the green,
let's suppose the green and the blue are positive and the red and the yellow are
negative.
Now how much overlap is there?
Well,
there'll be positive overlap where green overlaps blue and there'll be positive
overlap where red overlaps yellow.
But there'll be negative overlap where green overlaps red or yellow overlap or
where,
uh,
no,
we're,
we're blue overlaps read or where green overlaps yellow.
Okay.
Is that right?
Where,
yeah,
where blue overlaps or red or green overlaps yellow.
That'll be negative.
And this,
there'll be some angle at which those things exactly cancel out and you get no
net overlap,
no overlap,
bended role.
And we are interested in knowing what that angle would be.
That is how should hybridization be related to angles be related to structure?
Well,
so the question is what's that angle?
And there's a nice formula that isn't too hard to work out.
Why?
It should be that way.
Uh,
that relates s p m n s p.
N.
The values am an n to the angle that should be between them in order to have no
overlap.
So let's use that formula and look at several m s and what the angle is.
Let's look at s p with sp.
Sp squared with sp squared.
Spq Desk,
SB cubed and s p.
Anything with s p infinity.
What's sp infinity
that says the ratio of p to s is infinite.
So it's a pure p.
So what angle would a pure p orbital make with any hybrid?
Okay,
so those are the things we're going to talk about.
So first,
let's try the first one.
You can do the math,
the math for me.
Okay,
so it's s p one s p one m and n are one.
So the denominator is a square root of one.
That's one.
The Co sine of the angle is minus one.
What's the angle?
Okay,
why do angle has co sign of minus 180 okay,
good.
So that'll be linear.
And you knew that I'd been already,
didn't they teach you that in AP chemistry?
That if you have two s p orbitals that are linear,
or if you have bonds point opposite direction,
you use SAP hybrids for them.
If they didn't,
that's true.
Anyhow.
Okay.
Now how about sp squared?
Sp squared.
So we're going to have m and n are both two square root of four is two so it's
the angle.
Who's co sign is minus one half?
Anybody know what that is?
I don't think 60 plus I have settling.
It's a 100 flood.
It'd be minus a half,
right?
It has to be greater than 90 to be negative.
So that's gotta be 120 degrees and that's triggered also sp squared hybrids make
an angle of 120 degrees.
Now how about sp?
Three hybrids.
That's square root of nine.
So one minus a third.
That one probably isn't stored in your head,
but it's an interesting angle.
It's 109 and a half degrees,
which is the angle in a tetrahedron,
right?
So the methane,
which makes sp three bonds that the carbon has tetrahedral angles,
109 and a half degrees.
Now how about sp?
Anything with n equals infinity.
What's the denominator?
It's in Philly.
It's the uh,
uh,
what's the angle?
Who's co-sign is
90 degrees,
right?
So that,
that means that is what makes things Sig Button Pie,
right?
A Pr,
but all with any other hybrid has to be perpendicular to it.
So you want,
that's what we talked about sigma and Pi last time.
So the p orbital is pie and it's perpendicular to anything else.
90 degrees,
no matter what other hybrid.
Okay,
so now how about this particular,
when we have here where they're not,
where,
which s p cubed in sp one that turns out to be 125.3 degrees.
So that's what the angle should be.
If the carbon rate making one bond with sp and one with SPQ.
Right.
But the important thing here is that there's a relationship between hybrid
hybridisation of two orbitals on the same Adam and what the angle should be
between them.
Know,
Angela,
would you have an sp three and as high angels?
Well we have,
we're going to have to decide what determines the hybridization,
right?
And it could be different for for two bonds from the same Adam,
and we'll see examples of that.
So you'll,
that will become answered.
So it's,
it's if they're bonded to different kinds of things,
they may have different hybridization and we'll see an example of that central.
So we want to optimize the hybridization that is to get,
yeah,
this different weightings of the hybridized orbitals changed angle degrees there
too.
You could change the angle by moving the nuclei around for some other reason,
whatever it is.
And that would then change the hybridization of the carbon that's making the
bonds.
So it works both ways to change the hybridization,
you change the angle to change the angle,
you change the hybridization.
Okay,
now we want to optimize hybridization.
What do we mean optimize?
We meet,
we want to get the lowest possible energy.
We want to choose the hybridisation that'll give the lowest hybridization and
therefore a particular geometry for x.
H three is certain angles.
Okay.
Now,
let's think about that.
We're going to have one x electro,
one of the valence electrons of the x out of,
in each of three bonding,
atomic orbitals bonding to the hydrogen,
and whatever's left over goes into the fourth atomic orbital.
And we want to minimize the energy,
okay?
Now let's first look at it from the point of view of the bonds.
We want to make the strongest possible bonds.
We want to maximize the overlap in the bonds.
What hybrid gives the best overlap?
Sp can you make,
but we have to make three bonds,
right?
Sp you can only make two bonds.
So what's the best you can use if you want to make three bonds?
Sp squared.
So no matter whether it's Bh three ch three or Nh three,
all of the,
we'll overlap best in making three bonds.
If you use sp squared so that the bonds cry out,
use s use sp squared,
that'll maximize the overlap and minimize the energy of the electrons in the
bonds.
Okay?
But that's not the only game in town because there's also the other electron
that's on the atom.
If there is another electron,
hey,
because carbon has one in nitrogen has two other electrons.
So they should get a say in it too.
So the x atom,
which has to accommodate whatever's leftover says,
okay,
go ahead and make three bonds but get the lowest energy for the other electron
that I'm the only one responsible for.
Right.
So what's the lowest energy you could make for a pair of electrons or for a
single electron?
What's the lowest energy?
Valence.
Orbital.
Yes.
So the Adam says,
okay,
make your three bonds,
but make sure you,
you don't let s orbital go begging,
right?
Use the maximum you can have sr buttle cause otherwise you're using high energy,
atomic orbitals when you might not need to.
Now sometimes these would agree and sometimes they would fight with one another,
the bonds and the Adam.
Okay.
So from the point of view of the atom Boron with only three valence or electrons
all being used in bonds doesn't have anything else.
So it would certainly want to use three sp squared and leave the p orbital
vacant that gets the maximum utility out of the s right.
Puts the s where the electrons are.
So that's what Boron says.
Use Three SP squared's for the bonds.
What does carbon say?
Well,
no,
probably what does nitrogen say?
Nitrogen,
if it wanted to be the best,
Adam would put two electrons.
The unshared pair into the SR battle and one into each of the,
of the remaining three P orbitals.
Right.
That gets the maximum use out of s you don't want to waste s by putting it where
there's only one electron on the nitrogen atom you want to use it were there two
electrons?
Okay,
so nitrogen says we'll,
I'll use,
I'd prefer to use three P orbitals to make my bonds and put two electrons into
the SR bubble.
Okay.
Now what does carbon say?
Carbon says,
look,
I got four electrons.
Three of them are going to be in some kind of hybrid that's gonna make the bonds
and one of them is going to be something else.
But if I take the s out of one place,
I'm going to put it into the other one over all the four I'm going to use up all
the s character.
There's one electron in each of them.
Who Cares,
right?
So carbon really doesn't care from the point of view of the carbon atom about
hybridization.
It'll care for making for the bonds,
but it doesn't care for the uninsured,
for the unshared electron.
Okay.
But now we have to reconcile these two considerations.
So the uh,
uh,
the,
the Boron,
once we'll make the best bonds if it uses sp squared and it'll make the best
Adam if it uses sp squared.
So great.
They agree.
So Boron should really want to use sp squared hybrids for its bonds.
Remember,
those are the ones that form 120 degrees.
So it will be the pattern of a Mercedes star.
Yeah,
you can do,
if you're just looking at a nitrogen atom,
it's going to have two electrons in one of its orbitals and one in each of three
other orbitals,
right?
So those two electrons,
that orbital,
that holds two electrons should be as low as possible at energy.
And that's s so put two in s and one in each of the three P's.
And that'll give the lowest energy,
Adam with one electron in each of the four orbitals of,
well pardon me with two in one and three and the others three one in each of the
other three.
Okay.
So with any out with BH three,
they agree from both points of view of the strongest bonds in the Best Adam.
So it will certainly want to be flat and 120 degree bond angles.
Now how about ch three
ch three from the bonds wants to,
from the point of view of the bonds wants to be sp squared and the Adam doesn't
care so fine.
BSP squared,
B flat,
B Planar with 120 degree bond angles,
but it won't care quite as much as boron does.
So carbon says it'll,
it'll prefer to be plainer but not as strongly.
So it'll be easier to bend it,
right,
because it doesn't have this consideration of,
uh,
of leaving a p orbital vacant.
Okay.
And how about nitrogen?
Now you've got a fight on your hands,
right?
Because the bonds want to be flat at 120 degree bond angles,
but the Adam wants to use p orbitals 90 degree angles for the bonds.
So like the corner of a cube would be the nitrogen of the bonds would be going
out at 90 degree angles.
So here there's going to have to be some compromise.
Okay,
so,
so Nh three,
since it must compromise,
we'll won't be either perfectly flat or 90 degree angles,
but something in between.
It'll be pyramidal.
Okay.
Now are the predictions clear and the reason for them,
you and Judy is,
see now why it's the way it is.
Don't let me bully you into it if you don't really understand.
Dana,
can you explain the difference in what one?
For nitrogen again?
Yeah.
What we want to do is get the lowest possible energy.
The lowest energy for the bonds will be the best overlap.
You're making three bonds.
So sp squared will give the lowest energy as far as the bonds go.
But there also might be,
and that's the only game in town for Boron,
right?
But in carbon you have another electron you have to accommodate and there's a
question of what energy it will have,
even though it's not being shared.
And in nitrogen there are two of those other electrons.
Now,
the best orbital if had Adam for an electron to be in the lowest energy iss and
then in nitrogen they're going to be two electrons that want to be in an s
orbital.
If they do that,
they use up the s orbital and the,
the only thing you have left over to make the bonds is the p orbitals.
So now you've got to fight on your hands.
Are you going to have sharp angles and have it have the unshared parent and low
energy s orbital but weak bonds or are you going to have strong bonds sp
squared,
but put the unpaired electrons in a p orbital.
Okay.
Kevin,
did you have a question or that?
Answer it.
Okay.
Yes.
Can't hear very well.
Is there such a thing as an sp three orbitals
yeah.
What does,
what does sp three mean?
It means at a hybrid orbital,
a mixture of s and p with three times as much P as s.
Okay.
You could have that.
You could have three s p cubed bonds and for nitrogen for example,
and then an s p cubed hybrid in which the unshared pair lives.
Okay.
That would be a possibility.
Sure.
And that's the kind of thing I'm talking about here by saying it would be
intermediate between being 90 degree bond angles and hundred 20 degree bond
angles flat.
And he more questions.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm going to get to that just shortly here.
So it,
because we're talking about bonds,
bonds are local,
right?
Bonds don't go over the whole molecule.
Molecular orbitals go over the whole molecule.
And we've been talking thus far mostly in terms of molecular orbitals,
but now we're shifting to talk about bonds because what we wanted to do was talk
about bonds and I'll do a little about the philosophy of that shortly.
Okay.
So here are the predictions.
Bh Three should strongly want to be playing or be hard to bend.
Ch three should want to be plainer but be easy to bend.
And Nh three should be easy to distort out of plane so that it's not flat.
In fact,
fact,
not only should it be easy to distort,
it should prefer to distort in its lowest energy form.
Okay,
so now let's see if that's true.
Is it true that that unshared pair will compete for s character and therefore
make nitrogen pyramidal?
Now how do we know
there's our prediction distortion from the plane will weaken the bond and
deprive the electrons have s character.
So he doesn't want to be,
doesn't want to bend here.
Distortion from the plane weakens the bonds,
but it shifts s character to the loan electron where at least it's not wasted
because there is at least an electron there.
And in Nh three it weakens the bonds,
but it shifts as character from single electrons to a pair of electrons,
which is something good.
Okay,
so are these predictions true?
Well,
we need experiment.
How about X-ray for seeing the structure of,
of Bh three ch three Nh.
Three.
How about Nh?
Three have you ever seen an h?
Three have you ever smelled Nh?
Three.
It's ammonia.
So how about doing Xra audit?
Why not?
You can only use an x ray to see electrons cause the ones that are going to,
now that's not the main problem.
Yeah,
you can make it a crystal.
Do you have to have a crystal to do x Ray crystallography at Nh three is a gas.
Now you might say,
okay,
we'll cool it way down to liquid nitrogen temperature and then maybe it will
crystallize,
it'll be difficult to grow a crystal of ammonia,
but it's conceivable we might be able to grow a crystal of ammonia.
Okay.
Can we use the same trick for ch three and BH h three that one's a gas.
Ch three unfortunately if you get two of them together,
they react to get c two h six so you're never going to be able to cool them down
and get a crystal.
And the same thing is true of Bh three forms.
B Two h six right?
So forget crystals for this.
We can't use x ray crystallography,
the t,
the technique we've used so far to do this,
but there are other techniques for finding structure.
And the one we're going to talk about,
actually we're going to talk about too,
but we're going to talk about not x-ray.
We're going to talk about IRR.
We're going to talk about spectroscopy,
infrared spectroscopy and electron spin resonance spectroscopy.
Okay?
We're going to talk more about infrared spectroscopy next semester,
right?
But I'll show you just enough to get through the question that we're interested
in.
Now,
does that remind you of anything that moves like this in a high wind?
It's like an umbrella,
right?
In a high wind.
It blows inside out.
Okay,
so this is sometimes called the umbrella vibration of x,
h three and you can treat it with Arab and meets goldilocks as if it's one
dimension.
Just how much motion of all these atoms,
right?
How much motion?
You know what the masses are.
The atoms are,
you know,
the kind of motion you're interested in.
It's all coordinated.
So you're changing really just one dimension and moving all of these things in a
coordinated way,
back and forth,
right?
So you can treat it as an Arab and problem with a fictitious mass that reflects
the amount of motion of each of the four atoms while that's happening.
Okay,
so here's Bh three doing that out of plane,
bending vibration,
the umbrella vibration and ch three doing the same thing with its electron.
Now it turns out that Bh three vibrates 34 trillion times a second.
Okay?
And that's called 34.2 terra hurts.
That's how often it vibrates.
Ch three vibrates.
18.7 terra hurts.
So only half as fast as BH three.
How does this make sense?
Suppose the springs that your vibe that you're bending when you do this
vibration,
suppose it springs,
which set of springs is stiffer?
Bh three or the this a stiff spring,
make a vibration faster or slower,
faster.
So it says the springs are stiffer.
In Bh three it prefers to be plainer more strongly than ch three does.
Right now you might ask,
what might you ask at this stage?
When I tell you that it vibrates that fast,
that's not the question I want.
How do you know?
How do I know that it vibrates at that frequency?
Well,
so it would be a stiffer spring.
But how do I know?
Well,
when it vibrates,
the electric charge is moving back and forth,
right?
So the direction of the die,
there's a dipole there plus minus and it's moving back and forth.
And what does that create when you have charges moving back and forth?
Electromagnetic radiation,
right?
So electromagnetic radiation is going to come out as this thing vibrates like
that.
And it comes out with a shorter wavelength for BH three then for ch three right?
And that turns out that the wavelength is such that for BH three there are 1100
vibe vibrations waves in a centimeter,
right?
Short wavelength,
and it's longer wavelength,
only 600 waves in a centimeter for ch three.
Now,
uh,
we can also,
so there are different light would come out in for a red light of these two or
different colors of light infrared light.
Get absorbed.
That's how you actually measure it and that the,
remember the frequency of light has to do with the energies of the photon.
So in,
if you take the quantum mechanical view that you go from one quantized state to
another quantized state when you absorb or emit light,
then we know from this frequency that in one case that the two energy levels
you're talking about are separated by 3.26 kilocalories per mole.
And in the other case,
by 1.73 kilocalories per mole,
only about half as much is everybody on board with this so far?
So it's from the absorption of infrared light that we know how fast they vibrate
and therefore how stiff the springs are.
Okay.
Now just how stiff are they?
Well,
we can use Arabic for this point of view.
We have the amount of defamation,
which is our one dimension as it goes back and forth,
and we can assume that it's something like Hooke's law.
That's an assumption,
the distortion,
these springs,
and then we can adjust the potential,
how sharp the the Parabola is of potential energy until we get two energies that
are spaced like that.
Does everybody see what we're doing?
So here we do it on the left we get these lowest two energy levels and we
there's the parabola that does the trick.
So that's a strong,
a stiff spring,
strong planar preference.
And in the case of ch three to get that lower energy separation,
you need a broader parabola.
It's easier to bend.
The springs are softer.
Okay,
everybody see how that worked?
so,
so infrared spectroscopy then tells us that it first,
that it prefers to be plainer and second that it stiffer for Boron than it is
for carbon just as we predicted.
Okay.
Now how about for Nh three
for Nh,
three ut you see two absorptions in the infrared and they're very near one
another 1968 and nine 32 wave numbers that is waves per centimeter.
If we translate that,
it means that there are two energy levels,
that there's,
there's a lower energy level and then there are two that are very close to one
another in order to have these two different colors of infrared light being
absorbed.
How can we get this?
How can we get,
this is not Hooke's law.
Remember what happens with Hooke's law and the energy spacing?
What happens there even remember.
So this isn't anything like Hooke's law.
Where do you get to that are very similar to one another?
You remember
what I double minimum gives that?
So NH three must be a double minimum like this,
right?
And those must those,
the blue and the red one must be the one with three nodes.
And the one with two nodes,
there's also one with zero nodes and one with one node.
But those are both down at the bottom,
right?
They have the same energy because there's not enough overlap between the two to
make them split.
Right?
So these,
so the IRR spectroscopy of ammonia tells you it's a double minimum.
And also in order to get that spacing tells you how big the barrier is.
It costs three kilocalories of mole to make Nh three planar.
It prefers to be pyramidal,
okay?
And that splitting,
that tunnel splitting that we talked about before for those two levels is 37
wave numbers.
Remember there's also the two that are down at the bottom with zero and one node
and they're separated by only one wave number.
They're very close to one another.
But we can translate that into the tunneling frequency.
When you're down in the lowest energy levels,
how fast does it go back and forth?
And you remember how to do that.
If it,
if it's one wave number is two counts too small calories per mole,
not kilocalories.
And we use that,
that the thing that we talked about in lecture nine about how to go from,
from uh,
tunnels from splitting to tunneling rate.
And it turns out that in the ground state and the lowest energy state,
ammonia is flipping back and forth,
10 to the 11th times a second.
And in fact for a while that was used as a fundamental clock,
right here was something that you really knew the frequency of Hook when he was
trying to devise a clock that could tell where you were in longitude,
could have used ammonia if he'd had the technology to do it,
which would be an absolute frequency.
Okay,
so,
uh,
so IRR shows completely confirms what we said before that Bh three is stiff and
flat.
Ch three is easily bent and flat and Nh three is not bent,
but can tunnel back to forth by the umbrella motion.
Okay,
so now the other technique I want to tell you about is electron spin resonance
spectroscopy.
And it turns out,
and we don't have time to go into this,
that,
that what you know already that electrons are magnetic and some nuclei are
magnetic and you can get an inner,
a magnetic interaction between the nucleus and the electron,
which influences how hard it is to change the electron from being pointing one
way to being pointing another way.
That's a kind of spectroscopy.
See what color of light you need to make an electron.
Flip from being pointed one way to the other way,
but it's influenced by the magnet,
which is the nucleus.
But there's a neat thing about it,
which is that influence can occur only when the electron is inside the nucleus.
Where in a one s orbital is the electric is the highest electron density.
Remember the formula for a one s electron?
What's the,
what's the atomic?
Orbital.
It's a constant times what?
Either the minus row,
where's it biggest
inside the nucleus is the most dense part of the,
of the,
uh,
electron,
right?
So that when the electron is inside the nucleus,
it feels this effect when it's not inside the nucleus,
it does not feel the effect for the purpose of this spectroscopy.
Okay?
So we can measure how much s character there is in a hybrid orbital that holds
an electron by seeing how strongly the nucleus interacts with the electron.
Cause it happens only to the extent that it's s right?
So we can measure the percent of s character by measuring this,
the light that's absorbed by the electron,
Christopher Nolan,
the deal up truck
inside the [inaudible] time to save space.
There's different particles if we believe in it.
In fact,
it's,
it's a little more complicated than that because what's the kinetic energy if
it's in
the distance,
is zero
cool out big energies,
one over r suppose R is zero.
What's the kinetic energy infinite right now?
Well,
that means the electron is really zinging,
which means it becomes relativistic and its mass changes and all sorts of wild
things occur.
So it's actually that which causes this interaction.
So it's,
it's,
we'll leave that across the way here in Sloan physics lab.
Okay.
And take it from me that the amount of this splitting that you see in the Esr
spectrum depends on how much s character there is on the orbital.
Okay.
And you can worry about whether it's precisely inside the nucleus or just so
heavy and fast that it's,
that it's behaving weirdly.
Okay.
But anyhow,
that's the trick.
Okay.
So the singly occupied molecular orbital,
the one where there's only one electron in ch three,
uh,
we'll,
we'll give rise to electron spin resonance and the magnitude of this effect will
tell you how much s orbital areas.
Okay.
So let's look at it.
So there's,
and this is what I just said,
there's a line separation duty magnetic interaction,
and it occurs only if the electron spends time on the nucleus,
which happens only for an s orbital.
So we can measure how much s orbital.
Okay,
so here's a picture of Planar ch three and the orbital,
the singly occupied molecular orbitals Somo that contains the electron.
How much time is it spending on the nucleus?
Zero.
There's a node at the nucleus.
It's in a p orbital.
Now suppose we bend it so it looks like that.
Or we could look inside and it looks like that.
Now it's got some s character in that orbital,
right?
And if we make little boxes and blow him up to see what it looks like down near
the nucleus,
one of them has no density at the nucleus and the other has electron density at
the nucleus.
So you'll see magnetic interaction.
In this case,
if it's bent,
you'll see magnetic interaction.
And the more bent,
the smaller that angle from 120 remember the smaller the angle.
So it'll go go down toward 90 the Morris character,
there'll be more of it.
Okay,
so here's what you see for ch three bear in mind,
it has to be,
see,
it has to be a magnetic.
See,
it has to be c 13 h three not see 12 in order to see the splitting.
But at any rate,
the amount of this effect is 38 Gauss,
which are the units can be measured in,
and that implies that on average it's 2% s.
Now remember we already said that it's lowest energy form is flat with no ass,
but it's constantly undergoing this umbrella vibration.
So it spending time with different amounts of s character,
not zero as it vibrates,
and the average is 2%.
Now suppose I made the hydrogens heavier
by making them do pterygium.
So I make the Adams heavier.
You remember how that changes the shape of the wave function?
If I make things heavier,
here's here it is,
four H's moving.
What if it were do pterygiums that are moving?
How will the thing change?
It'll get narrower.
So as it gets narrower,
that means it's not bending as much on average.
And what should happen to the 38 gals if it doesn't bend as much?
I'll let you think about in a second.
No,
it's only when it's bent that it has s character.
And you see this effect.
If it were rigidly flat,
this splitting would be zero 38 would be zero.
What would happen if I change h two d so that it doesn't bend as much on
average.
So if you want me to say here,
right,
if we're more rigid,
it would.
How big would the effect be?
Bigger or smaller accounts?
Pardon me?
36 right?
So again,
it confirms what we're saying,
that it prefers to be flat.
It's only when it bends that you get this effect and it,
Ben's lasts with heavier atoms than with lighter Adams.
Wonderful.
So again,
it confirms what we said.
There's what CD three looks like it,
it's a little bit narrower and therefore a little bit less of this magnetic
interaction.
So this is a structural isotope effect.
Ch three spends more time,
more bent than CD three and thus uses more s character and thus gives a bigger
magnetic interaction.
Okay,
so again,
we've confirmed what we predicted.
Now here's one that we didn't work on and predicting his seat.
F three now what's,
what's changing h to f got to do?
Well,
it's going to be heavier.
So the same deal that would happen with deuterium should happen here,
but there might be more to it than that because now we have more protons and a
bigger nuclear charge of the atoms that were h before.
So they're going to to attract the electrons in the bond more.
Yeah.
So,
but there's another thing too that because the fluorines have a partial negative
charge and are bigger,
they have more electrons all together,
they'll repel one another.
Now what would,
if if the,
if the things attached to the central carbon get bigger and repel one another,
what effects should that have on it being bent?
Should it make it easier or harder to bend?
If these things are big here,
easier to bend from flat or harder if these things are harder.
Right?
So valence electron pair,
repulsion and all that should say that if c h three is flat,
what about CF three?
It should really be flat,
harder to bend if these things are bigger.
Okay.
But there's another point of view that you can take.
Yeah.
Which is that fluorine has the lion's share of the bonding electron pair.
The bonding electron pair in each of the CF bonds is spending more time near
fluorine than near carbon.
So carbon being a kg sort of character says,
why should I waste my valuable s character trying to stabilize these electrons?
They're spending their time on fluorine anyway.
Right?
Why don't I use it to stabilize that other electron that's only on me and not on
fluorine?
You got the idea.
So if carbon uses it's s character to go to the odd electron,
forgetting the ones that are mostly on flury in any way,
then that would make it more bent.
That would favor bending.
If you put the s character in the odd electron rather than in the bonds,
that'll favor using more p character in the bonds and therefore more bending.
So this is exactly the kind of thing that,
that uh,
that bacon would have liked,
right?
This is a crucial experiment.
They're two opposite predictions and you can do an experiment and find out which
one is true.
Is that that fluorine is bigger and negatively charged.
So it makes it more flat?
Or is it that the carbon says,
I want to put my electron,
the only electron I'm really solely responsible for in the car,
in the orbital with the most ass.
Right?
So this is a real horse race and you place your bets.
Okay.
Now how many people think it's the,
well,
we'll guess ahead of time,
how many people think that Fluor Enes are bigger and negatively charged?
So it will be harder to bend away from playing charity.
And how many people think that it's the odd electron that you want to put s
character in?
Well,
this is very close.
Okay.
So we'll have to look at an experiment.
Okay,
so this is the singly occupied molecular orbital of CF three.
It's mostly on the central carbon,
right?
But a little bit on the Fluor Enes.
And if you look in the middle,
you see that there's the s character on the carbon.
And if we measure the splitting,
it's 271 gauss.
What was it for methane
38 this is 10 times almost or whatever number of times that maybe like eight
times more s character than there was in that aid.
What's the conclusion?
It's much more bent.
Much more of the time than ch three is,
right.
Okay.
So that means it's 20% s that means that it's sp four in that almost sp three,
right?
So it's almost perfectly pyramidal.
Like methane would be,
right.
So it's the character of that odd electron wanting to be s that's,
that's uh,
controlling the geometry.
Okay,
now we're going to get to what Christopher wanted,
which is why the heck are we talking about bonds when we've been talking about
molecular orbitals all the time?
Well,
one reason is we wanted to talk about bonds.
That's how we got into this whole thing and asking what bonds are.
Okay,
but there are three different operators here and they have different motivation
and met and methods.
First there's the molecule deciding what to be and then there's the computer
doing quantum mechanics,
deciding what sh what the molecule should do.
And then there's you,
okay.
Trying to understand all this and these are different and let's see the way in
which they're different.
The experimental molecule,
all it wants to know it,
it doesn't care about Schrodinger all at once to do is get the lowest possible
energy.
So it minimize the total energy.
Kinetic plus Coolum energies of the electrons and the nuclei by just settling
down into the most comfortable,
lowest energy arrangement.
Okay.
That's what the molecule does.
It just gets happy.
Okay.
And once it does that,
then it has a certain structure,
a certain arrangement of the nuclei and of the electron clouds.
It has a total electron density,
which you can measure by X-ray.
It has certain energies that we showed measuring by IIR,
although you can measure them other ways as well.
It has nuclear electron density that we just measured by Esr.
It has dipole moment,
how much the,
there's a separation of positive and negative that you can,
that if it vibrates,
gives off.
IIR and so on.
So there are all these real things that come from the,
from the molecule,
just doing what comes naturally.
So it doesn't care about tritium.
Now you'll have a computer that comes along armed with Schrodinger's equation
and it knows it can't possibly solve the true Schrodinger equation.
It's too complicated.
So it'll do some approximation and tried to get,
uh,
an,
an approximate value.
So it'll minimize the total energy using the Schrodinger equation with some
realistic constraints.
For example,
using orbitals are using configuration interaction or using density functional
theory or some approximation.
Okay.
And what,
uh,
so it'll use like a limited set of atomic orbitals only say two s and they won't
use the five p orbital or the five g orbital or something like that.
Use self-consistent field or some correlation or delocalized molecular orbitals
come out.
Okay.
And what its goal is to get a useful prediction of the properties,
maybe the electron density,
maybe the energy,
maybe the vibration frequency,
maybe absorption of what colors of light get absorbed and so on.
So the goal of computer is to use any tricks that can get around.
It.
Can do and it doesn't care how hard it works,
right?
It's not something you have to be able to do on a piece of paper just to get
something useful and it will be validated.
The approximations you've made by experiment.
If it agrees with experiment,
then you can believe the computer,
but that doesn't mean you understand that what the computer did,
right?
It's a really complicated calculation and that's different from what you want to
do because your goal is to understand structure and reactivity with the
simplest,
realistic model,
not triggers fundamental equation because you don't have the brainpower to to
manipulate numbers that way and do all these integrals and so on.
Leave that to the computer.
You're goal is to try to look at things and understand,
oh,
that should be reactive with this.
That bond should be very stiff that that molecular structure should be very
stiff because the quote bonds are should be stiff.
Okay?
That's what you want to do is to develop an intuition that allows you to
understand structure and reactivity and you want the simplest obviously,
but realistic model and that to be both simple and realistic.
May Not be possible.
Right?
There's a certain tension there.
Okay.
So what kinds of things you'll talk about?
You'll talk about localized bonds.
You won't talk about these big things that are complicated and go over the whole
molecule.
I mean,
it's interesting to see,
for example,
that those are analogous to atomic orbitals and the kinetic energy plays a part
in them,
but that doesn't empower you to predict the properties of things.
Okay.
So you want to talk about localized bonds,
maybe pretend they're springs or something like that and what makes a spring
stiff or not stiff.
And that Christopher is why we have been talking about about springs and things
here rather than talking about molecular orbitals.
So you talk about these are as ideas,
bonds,
lone payers,
uh,
hybridization.
We talk about energy match and overlap and we'll talk beats talking soon about
homos and Lumos,
highest occupied,
molecular orbital,
lowest unoccupied molecular orbital,
and what a very important thing those are.
So we're gonna look at just little bits of things to try to find out what's
crucial and will allow us to understand,
we want them to be realistic.
We want them fundamentally to be based on something true like quantum mechanics,
not just on springs,
but we have to make it simple enough to understand.
So we're aiming for qualitative insight and we'll know when we're right,
if we agree with experiment,
and also if we agree with what the computer predicts,
even though the computer doesn't know why it predicted it,
it just grinds through and gets you a number.
But we want to understand why the computer gets that number.
Okay,
so let me just do one thing quickly here.
The pathological bonding,
or let me let you go to your next class.
We'll do pathological bonding next time.